[Musique]
comme chaque année le comité miss france
arrive avec son package une nouvelle
couronne une nouvelle miss mais aussi et
surtout une nouvelle polémique en effet
déjà je m'étonne toujours que ça arrive
toujours à la même période cette fois ci
c'est l'association osez le féminisme
qui a décidé de s'en prendre au célèbre
concours de beauté en allant même
jusqu'à attaquer la société de
production et le comité miss france
devant les prud'hommes je vous cite
l'élection de miss france est sexiste
rétrograde discriminatoire vous portez
donc l' affaire en justice en effet
l'association a souligné que le code du
travail interdit dans un recrutement
tout critère lié aux moeurs à à l'aja la
situation de famille ou à l'apparence
physique étant donné que depuis 2013 les
miss ont un contrat de travail qui les
lie avec la société de production
élections peut donc être vue comme un
recrutement c'est des concours donc à un
moment ça n'est pas du travail trois
femmes affirme d'ailleurs avoir dû
renoncer à se présenter au concours car
elle ne correspondait pas aux critères
imposés par les organisateurs de son
côté geneviève de fontenay figure
historique du concours explique jamais
considéré comme accor objets que j'ai
toujours voulu remettre des maillots une
pièce était né des maillots qu'ils
étaient vraiment des les beaux maillots
c'est n'avait rien de choquant une
élection de miss france se déploie de
malley d'humanité alors miss france le
concours itil sexistes
d'avocats alors merci à caroline mécary
avocate qui soutient la plainte de
l'association osez le féminisme caroline
voilà au delà de
voilà je suis je la suis enfin je la
suis chez je les ai suivis chez pascal
praud c'est vrai que suite à ses fans
elle est très très drôle oui on rappelle
caroline mécary mais madame camomille
bien sûr on peut le voir car lui même ça
vous dérange mais vous êtes chez vous il
embête c'est comme vous voulez pas ce
que pensent tous soit qu'elle sache et
moi je veux qu'elle soit à l'aise mais
voilà est ce que c'est vrai que c'était
une séquence incroyable regarde
ça va pas
supportable
je ne peux plus animé une émission de
télévision
café car je vous donne vraiment la vida
téléspectateurs de l'émission devient
gênante et même insupportable avec ce
brouhaha je vous assure que c'est vrai
tous les thèmes sérieux que vous traitez
sont dévalorisés et l'image des invités
qui vaut diverses on trouve dégradée ça
va
je supportable votre attitude sur et
pato de télévision
il faut reconnaître que pascal praud est
un merveilleux comédiens non mais non
mais franchement c'est drôle ça c'était
assez drôle et les deux vous êtes très
drôle moi je vois la ccc le direct c'est
ce qu'on aime aussi et camomille comment
ça vous êtes venu qu'à vomissez mais
devant tant d'énervement inutile je n'ai
eu qu'un mot kamoni
on va très bien en tout cas merci d'être
là et on embrasse parce qu'elle prouve
également et delphine wespiser qui dit
bien sûr que le concours n'est pas du
tout sexiste que c'est une ancienne miss
delphine un donc c'est normal pourquoi
pour vous le concours miss france et
sexiste je crois que la question qui est
posée au travers de la plainte d'osez le
féminisme
féminisme par donc c'est bel et bien la
question de la représentation des femmes
dans l'espace public et d'ailleurs ce
n'est pas osé le féministe qui dit que
ce concours est et sexiste c'est le haut
conseil à l'égalité qui dans un rapport
en 2019 a dit très clairement que le
concours miss france fait de la femme
véritablement un objet et qu'il a
quelque chose de totalement sur un
edward archaïque chaque année en fait à
l'arrivée du concours miss france chaque
année c'est vrai qu'on voit ce joli mic
arrive quand vous avez promis mme
carolyn deere scène delphine wespiser
vous êtes ex-miss oui vous comprenez ce
qu'elle ce qui sous-entend mais en fait
moi j'ai envie de vous demander quel est
votre but est ce que vous recherchez on
va écouter exactement la même chose que
ce qui s'est fait pour le concours
mister france c'est à dire que en 2013
le concours mister france a lui aussi
fait l'objet d'une plainte devant le
conseil des prud'hommes un des
concurrents qu'il a gagné à faire
requalifier le
sa prestation en contrat de travail
parce que la plainte a été déposée par
les trois femmes qui ont été refusés aux
concours et par l'association osez le
féminisme dit très clairement que les
critères de sélection sont des critères
discriminatoires et notamment le fait de
dire qu' on doit quatre célibataires
n'ont pas accès non mariés et non
divorcés pour le doit pas avoir d'enfant
ce sujet critères jeudi ce sont juste
des clippers en fait et c'est pour ça
qu'il ya plein d'élection d'un salon
avec ces critères il ya miss élégance
avec ces critères il ya miss france avec
ses critères et les filles sont libres
d'aller bien s'inscrire au bon coin le
kaiser
en droit du travail et on peut
considérer que le fait de participer à
un concours correspond à une prestation
du droit du travail ce sont des critères
qui sont concernés chamakh a pour devoir
m on va juger la cccd mars qui n'a rien
à voir avec ceux d'israël à savoir wii
puisque le concours et sexy c'est bien
je sors de ta 2d voilà vous incombe à
tout texte mais honnêtement aujourd'hui
on arrive à un stade où ça deviens plus
possible d'y accoler attaquent à tout et
n'importe quoi j'ai vu le dernier de
john howett hip hop et d'alcool il
dribble puis les filles il n'attaque pas
tout ça ça devient sexiste c'est tout
tout tout devient sexistes on ne peut
plus rire et dans ce monde tout est si
vous avez la parole
un jour vous allez finir par casser
entièrement les relations entre les
classes et messi parce que mal et on
savait bien attaquer comme chaque année
ces pots miss france ont nettement trop
de mal à personne effectivement là pour
elles sont très heureuses de faire des
efforts madame cours de manquer de faire
un disque avait pas de piercing tatouage
franchement y'a pas mort d'homme et au
bout d'un moment excusez moi vous nous
casser les pieds non mais vous est
insupportable et en plus et en plus vous
êtes faux derche parce que la démarche
dont vous que vous faites c'est unis
vont prendre du pognon et aux qualités
tout le monde est pour toi mais si on la
laissait pas les prix des gaz vient
maître assous il s'était amené à faire
ça et vous est dans une démarche
totalement de l'atlantique et la reine
des les freins en foutez voile arisée
qui prend lyon c'est la société je m'en
voulais la société endemol voilà un
produit qui offre un divertissement
mecs en rémunérant votre achat annoncé
comme hershey
voulons justement ce n'est pas dans un
concours excusez-moi cyril quand je vous
ai pas quand tout à l'heure j'ai évoqué
l'arrêt de la cour de cassation sur les
mister france c'est parce que la cour de
cassation a validé le fait de participer
au concours mister france était un une
prestation de droit ni d'avoir
mis en ligne des photos que j'ai compris
que j'étais le premier à faire une télé
réalité où déjà il était de bon ton de
l'attentât n'ont pas du tout plateau de
l'attentât premier choix la fedom story
l'ascenseur émission on doit avoir plus
faire recruter la requalifier des
candidats s'appelait amour gloire et
fortune parce qu'effectivement c'était
des acteurs et grâce à 7 à cette
émission à sous entre autres à essayer
de détourner promet de faire condamner
tout le monde parce que tous ces
concours la fm vous faites un amalgame
entre le concours le concours laissez
moi finir le concours miss france et bad
millions de télé réalité c'est un
divertissement et oui ça n'a absolument
rien à voir mais vous faites la même
démarche pour lui prendre du pognon sur
terre mais le spur aire géographique et
caroline dans ce cas la scala où les
candidates jouer oui si oui ou non ça
dépend quel jeu ça dépend comment les
bacs aux questions franches manquées par
agacer des roms
carolina moment où le concours mister
france qui est l'équivalent mener votre
mii et marchand est considérée comme une
prestation salariés on peut poser la
même question pour les miss mexique on
est sur la section des
jeunes allument un certain décalage à
votre démarche allait pas pour salariés
mais oui vous n'êtes pas en train de
vous dire mon dieu cette option les
exploits oui voilà la démarche elle a un
but c'est de pouvoir disqualifier le
concours puisque si elles ont un contrat
de travail il ne peut pas y avoir de
trucs discriminant c'est à dire on peut
pas leur demander leur version disent on
ne peut pas le respect
donc en fait non démocratiques mais en
fait vous utilisez la dotant départ à 10
heures
il n'existe ni jamais vous avez pas
recette à partir du moment où on
n'arrive pas vraiment à vendre autrement
que la représentation des femmes au
travers par exemple de ce concours miss
france est une représentation où elle
est comme un objet alors on utilise
les causes du drame et pour donner moins
le droit à coup la société avant
il ya un moment la vie est injuste il y
en a qui naissent riches qui en êtes
vous de la milesse moche ou d'isoler un
concours de beauté réel mais c'est un
concours de beauté on met les jeunes qui
sont très belles et ont fait rêver des
mecs pendant une soirée
les filles qui sont bons a bel et bien
mais c'est pas c'est pas tellement
d'autres choses c'est tout on veut pas
mettre dans un concours de beauté des
grands des rondes et mode
du tout non bien sûr qu'avec vous c'est
clair que la société n'aurait pas mangé
on l'aurait pas le mariage pour tous on
a respecté ma foi mais ça n'a rien à
voir
dénonçant des combats ont fait un
courrier si on est un con il fait rêver
du monde c'est pas moi c'est plus un
concours c'est quoi c'est une fois
c'est quoi
j'ai aucun problème avec ça j'ai
tellement la vie des oiseaux trois
espèces de la finir entre la majorité
des gens pour que au bout de 10 ans ou
20 ans on considère que ce que j'aime et
moi m'a d'abord une femme jean dauger
trouve sexy sexy contre ces jeunes sont
là je trouve que ce que vous êtes en
train de véhicules et c'est de dire des
jeunes filles qui ont envie de montrer
leur corps des jeunes filles qui ont
envie de défiler comme comme des
mannequins et bien gardé mais ce sont
des pauvres petites choses elles ne sont
pas intelligente elles ne sont pas
capables de sa victime quand on dit mais
quand on regarde le parcours de la
plupart d'entre elles on remarque qu
elles sont
après auquel son chef d'entreprise ou
qu'elle son avocate auquel son médecin
etc donc c'est les mettre elle sous une
couveuse en disant regardez ces pauvres
petites choses or ce ne sont pas des
petites choses décident mais ont des
familles à choisir un modèle de société
la balle est terrifiant me permets de
vous rappeler quand même que la plainte
qui a été déposée l'a été par trois
candidatures ont été reçues et au
courant il a refusé en aval mais il n'en
demeure pas moins que vous avez cité le
fait que ces elles sont mal comme des
mannequins le problème c'est que dans le
concours elles ne sont pas traitées
comme des mannequins c'est à dire
qu'elles n'ont pas de contrat de travail
qui les protège d'une exploitation non
meilleurs moyens très modestes
quand vous faites semblant de vous
intéresser aux femmes nous sommes ici
c'est imposer un modèle de société fini
où ça commence par un service à et pas
prendre l'interdire à ça et pas prendre
vous nous dire à ce que vous ne venez
pas ménagé non pas de votre modèle on y
lit que les énerve pas
voilà alors oui car li s'est pas dit non
mais madame pourquoi pour vous le mot le
mot de critères c'est une injure ou un
gros mot et ce n'est ni à une à julien
froment partiellement il ya des critères
c'est sexiste pour mais en droit du
travail quand vous êtes employé on n'a
pas à vous imposer par exemple m
jean luc reichmann fait un jeu il va
gagner de l'argent avec son jeu dont les
candidats doivent être ça
madame c'est un travail mais non mais là
c'est là où on se comprend pas bien ce
qu'on parle de droit du travail
non primé le plan dans la vessie au
plaît s'il vous plaît souple et
géraldine tout à l'heure oui non moi je
trouve que c'était une forme de
totalitarisme
je pense que on peut pas être tous bon
on peut pas être tous grands pareil bien
ce garçon veut pas être mais il zidane
avec le même âge et donc à partir du
moment où dans ce dans ce concours de
miss france bien qu'ils aient parfois
des critères un peu obsolète et ça j'en
conviens et bas ségala qui sont mis en
cause quant à lui lâché fifa mais bien
sûr que si vous voulez bien sûr et moins
de deux plages donc pourquoi être marié
iter esthétiquement ne faut pas être
tatoués ça s'éteint sur l'apparence
physique il ne faut pas être mariés
pacsés et divorcés savez la situation
familiale
c'est bien mais ça peut avoir des
enfants oui
ça fait rêver les brumes demandé à mes
copines savait rien garçons et non si
elle arrive en disant je suis marié j'ai
cinq enfants je suis bel et bien faire
avec moi ça fait rêver personne
mais s'avérait des personnages est
d'ailleurs vous savez pourquoi ça ne
fait plus rêver personne pourquoi on
vous regardait le concours et quand vous
regardez l'expression des individus sur
les réseaux sociaux à l'égard de ces
jeunes femmes mais il ya un déferlement
de ses clés l'audience
ce qui regarde les miss sont des femmes
elles ne le ressens c'est louis a
dénigré les regardant et que les
candidates ne devrait pas être rémunéré
pour le travail qu'elle fait moi j'avais
pris des requêtes avait créé un corps
est une hérésie utiliser cet argument
mais non je réponds non
comment dire et l'entraînement qui doit
être ferme on me dites pas que vous êtes
venu là vous êtes pointé juste comme ça
une fois vous qu'il le dise
je crois qu'il ya pas d'autres miss
france y
arriver tout seul comme ça du jour au
lendemain les excès
vous parlez tous vu de l'extérieur
effectivement je vous parle vu de
l'intérieur il ya une préparation de 1
mois
est ce que vous savez tous les cadeaux
qu'on reçoit mais c'est bien des sites
ils n'ont jamais pris l'avion on va dans
des destinations de rêve on est hyper
heureuse tous les soirs on a un petit
cadeau sur le lit où on est vraiment
gâté et ça ça n'a pas de valeur et
l'expérience miss france n'a pas de
valeur c'est une personne par région par
année rien que ça c'est c'est
fantastique et toutes les jeunes filles
parce que j'ai l'intention
de suivre gamme ça rêve de faire ça et
ça sympa de valeur si maintenant vous
dites ok je pose 5000 euros ce matin
pour participer à miss france c'est
impossible donc rien que ça voyez vous
voyez la beauté des douzièmes regarde et
vois le sexisme qui émane de ce que vous
dites alors oui il dit que le fameux
mister france mais on s'en fout
c'est la même
et revoilà voulait même canal haut et
ils ont été considérés comme étant en
étant soumis au droit du travail aux
gens non perçues et au jour tant sur le
sexisme et moi je pense que ce concours
il est sexiste parce qu'il réduit
évidemment des femmes à leur physique
mais pas seulement
[Applaudissements]
si on analyse bien le règlement et le
concept de miss france c'est un concours
dans lequel les français élisent une
femme la française bonne à marier donc
pas trop petit pas trop grosse pas trop
vieille célibataire parce qu'il faut
bien faire fantasmer les hommes donc je
trouve ça profondément sceptique il met
en avant des critères de beauté dans
lesquelles personne ne se retrouve son
mémoire il avait pas beaucoup trop et tu
te retrouves en est tout autre
il est sexiste et discriminés en bac
vous regarde moi
ce qui est important c'est de comprendre
c'est que les filles qui sont élues miss
france sont des filles qui se voit juste
tu veux le faire changer d'avis oui
depuis que si quand tu dois parler comme
ça durera plus aucune chance surtout que
si j'avais pas familles seront quelque
part on se serait jamais
rencontrons ce n'est pas du tout sexy
c'est un excellent temps court
vêtues toujours les mêmes les mêmes les
mêmes critères pour les femmes toujours
sur la beauté
delphine entre sonia rolland travail
malama chamelle à l'autre entre autres
balles à la main entre sylvie tellier
entre sophie thalmann elles sont
tellement différentes c'est vous qui est
réductrice et extrêmement sexy sans
cesse les mêmes étaient à la détruire
notre avenir je vous promets absence à l
époque voyant
avec toute liberté je vous promets
absolument impose rien vous avez toute
ligne en
plus de vivre quelque chose d'incroyable
les filles qui gagnent et même celles
qui ne gagne pas les dauphines elle
gagne un job en fait parce que toutes
ses fils adoptifs d'être
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui sont influence euse et
gagnent très bien leur vie et toutes les
autres c'est soit actrice animatrice et
voilà et en fait c'est assez important
pour elle c'est un tremplin et encore
pendant dix ans d'un tremplin en temps
on peut être sur ce tremplin la sainte à
saint tropez russe ou politique à
supposer que vous remportez fois que
vous que n'est pas d'accord vous obtenir
gain de cause et qu'effectivement ce
soir qualifié et que donc puisqu'ils la
requalification il ne peut pas y avoir
entre guillemets discrimination et donc
il ya plus de critères ça veut dire quoi
que vous voudriez que le concours miss
france puisque ouvert à tous pour peu
importe l'âge peu importe
ce que ça deviendrait je n'en sais rien
je n'ai pas la moindre idée mais en tout
cas on est content
parce qu'il ya une autre manière de voir
les femmes enfin que deux pas au travers
d'un concours qui met uniquement en
valeur une beauté qui est une beauté
mais
elle est femme intelligente aussi rdp
fort mauvais pour vous fait moins de
fautes comme un bonheur à ce que c'est
que ça oui mais c'est grâce à l'aspect
ampleur valoir comme ça t'es laissé
voile était l'esprit à 28% non à
12% fond